for England's 11 million renters life
can be difficult I've been forced to
move three times since the start of the
pandemic through a combination of
no-fault evictions so like section 21s
and rent Rises now a change in the law
is coming that the government size will
help people like Jasmine by ending no
fault evictions I feel like more needs
to be done I feel like the bill doesn't
go far enough I say that because
um the way that I've been forced out
each time is it may have come with a
section 21 notice but in the end you
know I've been advised there's no point
in fighting your section 21 notice if
you can't afford to pay the rent
increase housing secretary Michael Gove
has insisted he is on the side of
renters and the plans will give more
powers to people like Belinda who says
her landlord has repeatedly refused to
fix mold and leaks and threatened her
with eviction the good news is that even
at a time when people are facing real
pressure on their household budgets that
rents in the private rented sector have
risen less than inflation and of course
in this legislation we affirm that rents
can only rise once a year and if rents
are thought to be unfair there's an
ombudsman now that we're creating
the bill will also give landlords new
powers to evict tenants that are
anti-social or behind on their rent it
will bring in new standards that Force
landlords to keep their properties safe
and well maintained and it will end
blanket bans on people on benefits or
with children
but some critics including conservative
MPS say it will drive landlords out of
the sector he was given to keys and
there's one two three four five six
seven front door keys Lisa has
experienced a problem tenant and has
used a no-fault eviction when he didn't
pay his rent I issued the section 21.
and which I'm very glad I did but he
didn't go out on the date he was he
lived there rent free for six months but
when she found out this law change was
coming she felt she had no choice but to
sell it really does force your hand and
I decided to sell and I'm pretty sure
there's going to be quite a few
landlords doing the same thing and
selling
housing campaigners before the
legislation a huge opportunity but with
house building targets scrapped and
Rising interest rates will it be enough
to fix the crumbling foundations of
Britain's rental market Liz Bates Sky
News North London